in der grundlegung zur metaphysik der
sitten geht es um das gute und in der
religion schrift die kant auch noch
verfasst hat ein bisschen später die
wiener nächsten sitzung behandeln da
geht es um das böse
ich hatte schon gesagt es gibt
verschiedene kandidaten für das gut und
böse und so wollen wir auch die erste
frage und jetzt stellen was ist nach
kant eigentlich gut zu nehmen noch mal
wiederholen das kann sein es ist die
person die gut ist es kann die handlung
sein wie gut es kann der wille sein der
gutes können die umstände seien gibt
ganz verschiedene kandidaten in der
zweiten frage habe ich eigentlich jetzt
schon die antwort genannt
jetzt ist nach kant nämlich nur der
wille der eigentlich gut genannt werden
kann wir wollen uns aber die frage
stellen warum es ist denn nur der wille
den weg gehen können und ich etwa die
handlung oder die person
und dann wollen wir uns nachfragen
wiedererkannt vernunft und das gute
miteinander
das
ja jetzt gibt's ja ein ganz ganz
bekanntes zitat
was sie bestimmt schon mal gehört haben
es ist sagt kann überall nichts in der
welt überhaupt auch hause derselben zu
denken möglich was ohne einschränkung
für gut könnte gehalten werden als
allein ein guter wille
verstand witz urteilskraft und wie die
talente des geistes sonst heißen mögen
oder mut entschlossenheit beharrlichkeit
im vorsatz
eigenschaften des temperaments sind ohne
zweifel in mancher ab sich gut und
wünschenswert aber sie können auch
äußerst böse und schädlich werden wenn
der wille der von diesen natur gaben
gebrauch machen soll und dessen
eigentümliche beschaffenheit darum
charakter heißt nicht gut ist also gut
ist deswegen nur ein guter wille weil
ein guter wille
intrinsisch gut ist ein guter wille kann
so sagen kann
gar nichts böses oder schlechtes haus
sich hervorbringen er bringt jetzt die
andere beispiele noch wie zum beispiel
am mut entschlossenheit und
beharrlichkeit das sind alles tugenden
könnte auch sagen sekundärtugenden weil
sie eben nicht intrinsisch gut sind ich
kann sekundärtugenden wie zb eben
geschlossenheit auch für das böse
benutzen ich kann auch ein banküberfall
mit entschlossenheit durchführen dann
ist aber die sekundär tugend der
entschlossenheit nicht wirklich gut
sondern sie ist in different dagegen ja
also es geht es ein bisschen diese
richtung zwischen primär und sekundär
tugenden betrug und wie gerechtigkeit
ist intrinsisch gut
eine sekunde der tugend wie der
heiligkeit entschlossenheit eben nicht
und glücks gaben es erkannt da verhält
sich genauso wir können also auch nicht
im glück dass gute wirklich finden macht
reichtum ihre selbst gesundheit und das
ganze wohlbefinden und zufriedenheit
mit seinem zustand unter den wagen der
glückseligkeit machen mut und hierdurch
öfters ein übermut wo nicht ein guter
wille da ist mit dem einfluss des selben
aufs gefühl und hiermit auch das ganze
prinzip zu verhandeln die richtige und
allgemein zweckmäßig mache
ja also auch
das glück ist nicht drin sich gut weil
es häufig zum übermut führt
also ausschweifend und so weiter und so
fort glück streben ist nach kant
glückseligkeit ist nach kant nicht das
eigentliche gute ja gegen wen wendet er
sich jetzt hier wohl sie können sich
denken in welche welche klassische
position hat ethisch die ansicht
vertreten dass das gute vielleicht das
ziel der glückseligkeit steht dass die
kommunistische idee die wir eben unter
anderem von aristoteles kennen aber
die gibt es natürlich dann auch noch bei
den epicor ihren und so weiter und so
fort also hier gibt es verschiedene
glücks tätigen der antike und dagegen
wendet sich kann ganz ausdrücklich weil
eben im glück selbst keine kontrolle
liegt und weil kann sagt das gute ist
eigentlich nur das moralisch gut nicht
das nützliche mich das glücklich
[Musik]
also hält wird er noch weitere beispiele
ohne grundsätze eines guten willens
erkannt ganz unten können sie die
anderen
eigenschaften die wir besitzen können
höchst böse werden und das kalte blut
eines bösewichts macht nicht allein weit
gefährlicher sondern auch unmittelbar in
unseren augen noch
verabscheuungswürdiger als er ohne
dieses dafür würde gehalten werden
sekundärtugenden wie beharrlichkeit die
können sogar besonders böse werden wenn
sie einfach nicht richtig geleitet
werden das heißt ganz begriff des guten
ist ein reflex iva begriff ein begriff
der immer auch eine anleitung enthält
den enorm enthält der regel enthält wie
wir uns verhalten sollen aber das gute
ist da kann immer auch ein maßstab eine
anleitung
und jetzt kommt noch was ganz
entscheidendes kann zeigt nämlich der
gute wille ist nicht durch das was er
bewirkt oder ausrichtet nicht durch
seine tauglichkeit reichen irgend eines
vorgesetzten zweckes oder allein durch
das wollen sondern nur allein durch das
wollen an sich gut und für sich selbst
betrachtet ohne vergleich weit höher zu
schätzen als alles was durch ihn
zugunsten irgendeiner neigung
hervorgebracht werden könnte das ist
jetzt ganz wichtig es geht ihnen nicht
um die handlung da haben wir schon der
zweite den zweiten grund das gute
besteht nach kenntnissen der
glückseligkeit aber auch nicht im handel
nicht in der handlung und zwar jetzt
wenngleich durch eine besondere um gunst
des schicksals
sagt er hier eine besondere um gunst des
schicksals oder durch die kärgliche
ausstattung eine stiefmütterliche natur
er die person diesem willen gänzlich an
vermögen fehlte es ihm fehlt es seine
absicht durchzusetzen wenn bei seiner
größten bestrebungen wir noch nichts von
ihm ausgerichtet würde und nur der gute
wille freilich nicht etwa als ein bloßer
wunsch sind als die aufbietung aller
mittelzuweisungen zeige was sind übrig
bliebe so würde er der wille wie ein
juwel doch für sich selbst glänzen als
etwas das sein vollwert in sich selbst
hat
ein guter wille und das gute ist im
transit gut es ist auch absolut gut es
ist unabhängig gut von dem wirkungen die
aus team folgen und jetzt hat er hier
eben diesen vergleich mit dem juwel ein
juwel strahlt eben an sich die
nützlichkeit oder furchtlosigkeit also
ob jetzt diese gute wille besonders
viele gute handlungen zur folge hat oder
auch nicht das ist die nützlichkeit die
kann diese werte des absoluten film
weder etwas zu setzen noch abnehmen sie
würde gleichsam nur die einfassung sein
um ihn im gemeinen verkehrt besser
handhaben zu können wo die
aufmerksamkeit der die noch nicht genug
kenner sind
auf sich zu ziehen
nicht aber um ihn kennen zu empfehlen
und seinen wert zu bestimmen also die
die vergleichsbasis ist hier ein guter
wille ist wie ein juwel und die guten
handlungen oder vielleicht auch nicht so
guten handlung die daraus hervorgehen
die sind nur äußerlichkeiten die
entsprechend nicht dem juwel glänzt soll
nur der einfassung also
der umgebung könnte man sagen wie dieser
wille eben transportiert wird ist eine
ganz berühmte ganz berühmte vergleich
den kanten und jetzt müssen wir uns mal
überlegen wir das weiter bestimmt er
sagt es liegt gleichwohl in dieser idee
von dem absoluten werte des bloß in linz
ohne einigen nutzen bei schätzung der
sieben anzeigen zu bringen ist etwas so
befremdliches dass ungeachtet aller
einstimmung selbst der gemeinde vernunft
mit derselben dennoch ein verdacht
entspringen muss das vielleicht bloß
hochfliegende fantasterei insgeheim zum
grunde liege und die natur in ihrer
absicht um sie unseren willen ruf zu
regieren beigelegt habe falsch
verstanden sein möge daher wollen wir
diese idee aus diesem gesichtspunkt auf
die prüfung stimmen kann sagt also das
absolut gute ist allein ein guter wille
und wendet aber selbstkritisch ein das
ist doch ziemlich befremdlich
ja ist das vielleicht nur eine
hochfliegende fantasterei eine
stilisierung wenn wir den willen so
idealisieren dass wir sagen er ist ein
das gute er ist wie ein juwel anzusehen
das ist dieses problem was ich kann hier
stellt
und es geht ihm hier eben nicht darum
dass wir nach unserer natur anlage
gut genannt werden können
sondern dass wir nach unserer vernunft
anlage eigentlich gut sind
bin doch ein war interessiert denn da
die vernunft nicht tauglich genug ist um
den wilden anziehung der gegenstände
dasselbe und zur befriedigung alle
unsere bedürfnisse die sie zum teil
selbst sehr vielfältig sicher zu leiden
als zu welchem zwecke ein eingeplanter
natur instinkt fähige wiese geführt
haben würde gleichwohl aber uns vernunft
als praktisch vermögen das ist als eine
solches das einfluss auf den löwen haben
soll genau zugeteilt ist so muss die
wahre bestimmung derselben seien nicht
etwa in andere absicht als mittel sind
an sich selbst guten willen
hervorzubringen und zum schlechterdings
fünf nötig war woanders die natur all-in
auszahlung ihrer anlagen zwecken mäßig
zu werke gegangen ist kann sagt das gute
des guten willens liegt kein ganz eng
zusammen mit unserer vernunft unsere
vernunft jetzt durch die beziehung auf
unserer vernunft kann unser wille gut
werden das ist auch noch eine spannende
sache was für eine vernunft hat jetzt
hier kann im sinne es gibt zwei
auffassung vernunft von vernunft es gibt
einmal die instrumentelle vernunft das
ist eine auffassung von 95 danach wir
vernünftig dann sind wenn unser verstand
und es die mittel vor gibt also die
instrumente wie wird mit durch die wir
einen bestimmten zweck verfolgen können
ist die sogenannte instrumentelle
vernunft die meint jetzt könnt ihr aber
nicht sein kann meint eine moralische
vernunft eine vernunft die nicht nur
instrument ellisons absolut sagt was wir
tun sollen
um aber den begriff eines an sich selbst
hoch zu schätzen und ohne weitere
absicht guten willens so wie er schon
dem natürlichen gesunden verstand
gesunden verstand bei wohnt und nicht
sowohl geleert als vielmehr nur
aufgeklärt zu werden bedarf diesen
begriff denn der schätzung des ganzen
welt unsere handlungen immer oben an
steht und die bedingung alles übrig
ausmacht zu entwickeln wollen wir den
begriff der pflicht uns nehmen der den
eines guten obzwar und der gewissen
subjektiven und einschränkungen wir
schenken den hintern es enthält aber
doch weit gefehlt dass sie in verstecken
unkenntlich machen sollen ihn vielmehr
durch abstimmung heben und desto heller
hervor scheinen lassen das jetzt ganz so
sagen kann sagt das gute der gute wille
hängt ganz entscheidend mit unserer
schlecht zusammen dann würde man doch
aber jetzt erst mal sagen das gute hat
doch gar nichts mit der pflicht zu tun
pflicht ist doch eigentlich immer etwas
was ich ungern tun weil sonst wäre sie
doch keine pflicht warum ist nicht das
gute das wenige das wenige was ich immer
selbst schon gut tue was ich von mir
selbst immer schon gut tue oder
dasjenige was als individuum möchte
pflicht ist doch immer etwas was von
außen auf mich ein drink was im grunde
genommen gar nicht meine autonomie
bedeutet deswegen jetzt natürlich ganz
entschieden davon ab was kann unter
pflicht versteht ganz besteht und der
pflicht eben etwas was die allgemeine
vernunft allen individuen vorschreibt
das betrifft nicht pflicht betrifft
nicht mich als individuum sind die
betrifft jedes vernünftig gewesen aber
eben auch ein ähnliches wesen also die
pflicht ist nur dann der fall wenn wir
nicht immer schon das gute rolle und das
merken sie jetzt bestimmt ein
verbindungspunkt die pflicht die ist
deswegen nach kant notwendig mit blick
auf das gute weil wir endlich gewesen
sind hier kommt wieder dieser begriff
diesmal um mit der physik um ins spiel
was wir bei leibnitz kennengelernt hatte
ich mache dann auch oben rechts den link
dazu rein die pflicht tritt nach cannes
nur deswegen mit blick auf das gute auf
weil wir als solche immer auch schon
diese trägheit in uns haben
sie sehen hier gibt es den bezug von
guten gleich wieder zum bösen wir sind
nach country apriori vor aller erfahrung
immer schon auf das gute hingerichtet
sondern wir haben uns ein tendenz auch
einer solchen trägheit eine art
widerständigkeit gegen das gute deswegen
müssen wir das gut immer wieder aufs
neue versuchen zu erkennen und auch in
unserem handeln immer wieder neu
angeleitet werden entscheidend ist aber
dass diese pflicht im grunde gar nichts
von außen ist was uns vorgesetzt wird
sondern im grunde genommen wollen wir
wenn wir uns nur gut genug betrachten
gut genug reflektieren im grunde
eigentlich immer schon auch das gute
also hier gibt es eine grosse spannung
bei kann einerseits wollen wir das gute
nicht faktisch oder nicht unmittelbar
sondern wir haben eine eine trägheit ein
hang es erkannt ein hang zum bösen auf
der anderen seite wenn wir uns als
vernünftig gewesen wirklich bestimmen
wirklich verstehen die nicht nur
irgendwie trieb oder individuelle
neigungen nachgehen dann wollen wir
eigentlich im grunde doch das gute also
hier sehen wir bei kant eine riesen
spannung zwischen unsere natur mit blick
auf das gute und das böse und natürlich
kommt dass die pflicht deswegen ins
spiel weil wir nicht perfekte wesen sind
das heißt hier scheint sich kant auch
implizit zumindest auf leibnitz begriff
diesmal um mit der physik zu beziehen
müssen dann in den folgenden sitzung
noch genau untersuchen wie jetzt das
böse bekannt genau ausgesehen hat und ob
es eben angemessen als
trägheit manometer physikum bestimmt
werden kann kant hat hier noch ganz
viele andere dinge sagen das war es
jetzt mal als einführung und ich bin
dann schon gespannt auf die diskussion
und auf die nächste sitzung in der es um
das böse bei kant geht